last week I showed speed promoted
Paradox crypto which was widely
criticized to be a scam and he
apologized and I confronted the founders
behind this crypto coin only now one of
the founders has gone full internet
tough guy and is making threats towards
the people who criticized him
when it comes to you personally myself
yeah for spreading all that fake [ __ ]
lies on my name
what's when I catch you I'm gonna smash
your teeth in this double down by itself
would seem so insane but it actually
gets worse so this is a full expose on
amio talio the founder who in my opinion
is a danger to himself and others in
addition to being a scammer so we'll
discuss all of this but first let me
bring you up to speed on what's happened
so far as many of you know I confronted
Paradox crypto on a live stream a week
ago and things went pretty badly for the
two of them there were two brothers they
kept deflecting basic questions about is
this a get rich quick scheme or not and
they also kept saying that like it's not
that you think we're a scam you just
must not like us you don't think we're a
scam you just you just think that we're
not gonna no I think you're scared you
must not like the way we dress or the
color of our skin all it is all it is is
because we're in your we're not your
average suit and tie kind of guys maybe
you don't like the color of fast skin
which is a pretty pretty shocking
allegation when only an hour earlier I
was a man of dignity and a man of the
people you are a man of dignity and a
man of the people because you are
obviously exposing fakes I don't know
why I just keep going from awesome guy
to horrible person whenever I confront
one of these people but at this point
it's just the coffee Zilla but honestly
I thought the story was gonna end here
for me because even though they've made
a response video about this a couple
days ago where amio talio the founder
tried to talk a lot more carefully and
considerately about his crypto coin I
watched it and realized it wasn't worth
my time to cover because a voice
critical already covered this and I felt
like he had done a great job already but
also B it was basically all the same
counter arguments that I had already
debunked on a two-hour live stream but
yesterday something changed amio talio
decided to Double Down by going from a
crypto scammer into an unprofessional
goon who threatens people who criticize
him what's worse is that he didn't just
threaten people with big platforms like
me or or moist critical no no no no he
was nice to us he told me after I
toasted him and his brother for two
hours on a live stream good luck on your
future Ventures no instead of going
after us amio talio decided to Target a
small Tick Tock creator that dared to
criticize him the exact same way I did
but instead of saying good luck on your
future Ventures he said this what should
I catchy
smash your teeth in
every single time
you look at your face in the mirror
you're gonna see your broke up nose bust
up in 20 different places that's what
I'm gonna do that because of yours right
if it was funny in it you thought it's
funny just 12 months on the internet
although I'm not an internet guy imma
put your email I'm gonna put 10 bags
down to anyone that shows me this guy's
address I'll give him 10 bags and then
I'll see what you're gonna say when I
come there because I think you think I'm
just some internet
yeah
so see you very soon
now this is so annoying to me it's the
ultimate internet tough guy act you
choose the smallest voice criticizing
you and you say okay I'm gonna bash your
teeth in if you don't shut up like why
not say that on a live stream to me it's
also the dumbest thing too because
you're literally threatening somebody
online recorded you're saying you're
putting a bounty on them like you might
get arrested doing that and honestly
this thing was so unhinged that even
after seeing a screenshot from amio
talio's Snapchat I didn't even believe
like this was real I thought it might
have been a deep fake or something he
says 5K to the person who grabs this guy
who criticized him and brings him to me
I want to see this Troll's face in real
life and then he asks for his mom's
address I honestly thought I was trapped
in some kind of paradox metaverse
nightmare that I'd have to like pay para
coin to get out of there just is no way
in my mind someone could be that stupid
to voice physical threats over a
recordable voice memo and then have
screenshots of them putting a bounty on
somebody and it was doesn't until I
reached out to the person who's actually
threatening all of this Naim that I
actually believed any of this was real
for sure so the CEO basically yesterday
the CEO of paradox messaged me he
straight away went with friends he's
like said I'm gonna put a 10K bounty on
you like I'm gonna make people come
after you look for you took a screenshot
of my Snapchat profile and put it on his
story telling people to come look for me
now obviously these are pretty shocking
allegations so I wanted to make sure
there was no doubts given how serious it
is so I reached out to Paradox metaverse
to try to hear their side of the story
they decided not to respond but they did
respond on Discord about it confirming
some of this we have the brother of amio
talio responding under the handle
Professor you can see on Discord he's
labeled the co-founder and someone gives
naeem's Tick Tock account he says hey
amio's making it worse his brother says
just a fudder getting told off nothing
to worry about quote each of them I
guess the critics have contacted us to
pay them to remove the posts isn't that
called blackmailing now here he seems to
confirm the threat saying they were just
telling them off but he also implies
that they were blackmail which is a new
allocation so I reached out to them for
a comment about that no response so I
asked Naim about it and he of course
says well that never happened although I
don't do that stuff like that's just
weird why would I try and blackmail
someone and so we have no evidence of
this blackmail story but we do have
evidence of violent threats so amio's
brother finally admits on Discord that
the founder and face of the company
sending threats via voicemail is hardly
a good look he responds I do agree
emotions can run High when you're being
attacked and everyone is believing it
over the truth and it's overshadowing it
um I guess the strategy here being the
best way to stop people from thinking
you're a scam is distract them with
threats of criminal violence now I'm not
sure this is such a great move for them
and it calls into question amio talio's
whole Persona about like he's just
ignoring the haters I've got plenty of
hairs I just ignore them just ignore
them why do you look carry on hey you
know keep stacking bread well so much
for that apparently he only follows this
advice when someone bigger than him is
talking to him online if you're a small
Creator he will threaten your life now
it may not surprise you to learn that
this whole story didn't stop there
because I started to do a deep dive on
this guy and it turns out he actually
has a history of this even though he had
a low profile online he's apparently
lived a lot of his life being a tough
guy and threatening people for seemingly
no reason like for example he got in a
fight with this guy at the gym uh who
didn't enjoy being filmed
taking pictures what
don't worry don't worry one second and
it's not just that either he got in a
fight with his luxury car dealer who
goes by the name cash as well he makes
some pretty disgusting statements about
the guy's family which I will be
bleeping out but I think you can uh read
between the lines here
Hanky Panky dad your [ __ ] stupid kids
yeah you're [ __ ] brother that needs
to come out of the [ __ ] closet I told
you a lot of them yeah so uh he seems
horrible I mean not exactly the stable
guy you want running your Investments
right this is the kind of guy who will
literally just post himself online
threatening crimes that's what's most
shocking about it like he will film
himself trying to commit crimes and then
post it on YouTube for example he
literally did this with a attempted
theft
open the boot
don't record me help me come help me
huh we're just making sure that no one
can steal this so we're just making sure
see if it fits in the booth it don't
we'll put it back
now I don't know what his defense is
here maybe he would say this was all a
prank or a joke or at least he should
have been able to say that if he hadn't
basically confessed right after that in
the same video
cool we are the worst we are the worst
criminals ever we got cool wow I can't
believe I'm saying this but that was the
first thing amiotalio has said that I
agree with he's the worst criminal ever
hence the title actually it's not even
me saying that he he says it himself and
then says the crime he just failed to do
we just need one of those caught Little
Robot machines and
he's walked and he's like okay
we're just making sure literally that's
his Mo he broadcasts himself like making
threats attempting theft and then only
does that when he thinks he can get away
with it I mean it's just the worst I
could keep showing examples but I think
this is the last one I'm going to show
this one though shows especially what
kind of a delusional narcissist this guy
is the biggest [ __ ]
watch what happens to you
and you think I'm going to calm down I'm
a big man bro make one phone call bro
yeah but you think I'm gonna come down
to you of you don't worry you'll see
what time it is in it don't worry don't
worry you carry on
carry on yeah you can't [ __ ] everyone
don't need to swear no one's kids
problem you watch this guy is so
unbelievably full of himself I I don't
truly don't understand how people see
this stuff and think like it's alpha or
cool it's pathetic that's basically what
I wanted to talk about I just wanted to
follow up on the last video with this
update and just uh talk about the
character of the guy behind Paradox
crypto